hey guys Ryan the righteous here hi I'm
Selina Meyer Selina Meyers is here so
today we're gonna check out a video from
bad lip reading now I have a confession
to make as a youtuber I have not seen
bad lip reading
I've heard of plenty about it I hear
they're hilarious
I know she hasn't seen them either but
it's redneck Avengers Tulsa Knights a
bad lip reading of marbles The Avengers
finally excited to see what the [ __ ]
this channel is all about protecting the
red white and blue and even some
Americans to god it's been a movie
previously on redneck Avengers I heard
your sister made out with Lee barfi yeah
she's nachos are spicy
hahahaha and you keep my pajamas ooh
fancy or mine or leather the people at
my school want to do stuff like I
sculpted mmm dang it Percy feel good you
presume doughnuts
it was too many listen you got your
sweat
oh my knife now I want you to have it
you know why aren't you look at if they
don't want your turn nerve quit your
fussing I'm trying to help you Wow would
you happy perfectly why didn't it taste
right don't you like pig dude that's Pig
I'm a buffoon hey you said it not me you
listen to me I need to go poop ha ha ha
you can't haha big guy huh you've been
texting Rachel adorable emojis and it's
creepy call violet hey guess what did
you grow up in my face again no okay try
to figure out what voice I'm doing use
the Force
Yoda
you're way too pretty sure I think I'm
in love you say what and even though you
and me your family who says that we
can't be together
Oh sir she likes you
yeah you seen her tattoo you
you got a kazoo here man this is crabby
oh yeah well then when are you gonna eat
your carrots oh no man I want to eat him
but like see what happened man she got
into my stash she breaks into my room
and stuff never gonna do eat your supper
okay it was just one time Bob hey you
seen my beef jerky - I did not yeah I'm
a depart for a flavor listen man step on
your danglers digs maybe get your
grandma to lift weights she's kind of
small it sounds like you're disappointed
cuz she's disappointing grandma's can't
do things like that you really want her
legs to be impressive
I mean she's basically spaghetti but a
laptop a table and that's how you Sam my
supposed to be in here my daddy doesn't
want me to flirt with you but I want to
was that right so we should go to the
old bridge
each other yeah what about little buddy
sweetie he and a squabble now I guess so
since you ran over his horse oh yes
darling
the buddy told me everything like how
you like your chicken strip on the
underside of the bread what do you
thinking you gonna run the Piggly Wiggly
cuz you gonna get me some skittles
cigarettes and a big pouch of big league
chew on the next redneck Avengers hey
what you guys doing out here probably
just more hide-and-go-seek
we shower down yeah you can't sequence
day you remember why I love you my
donkey feet it's the best friend there
really baby collection is it for me
little bored is st. even want to dim
books I want to read then you should
burn it I guess yeah now I might have to
pick you up and spit out all your faux
head huh of course I'm drinking I'm
bored Hank
no I don't have my bestest wig on I know
something about Jeb don't tell him why I
want to buy coffee protecting the red
white and blue neighbors here is too
applause [ __ ] brilliant
now I've heard about these guys forever
talk about perfect voicing like it
really looked like really did look like
dead-on yeah look like they were
actually saying those words that was
[ __ ] impressive but the script was
like amazing - hey I mean it's funny
yeah I mean it's not like a story being
going on but the most the sentences like
they match the voices perfect I wonder
how much time goes into these videos
very impressive redneck I was watching
it going like you know the Avengers
might be cool if they were all southern
actually I think it I think it would be
pretty sweet if they were like badass
southern or not like these hillbilly
ones have a redneck boys but no that was
fantastic thank you guys so much for
telling me we'll watch that I've just
been lagging home checking out other
channels but that was great gilina had a
ball of a tagging of all time you were
just really foes yeah it's okay it's
okay
it's all right to have a good sense of
humor anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out show Lena's
channel it's a lot of fun on there and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where if we get enough
followers product placement and let's do
a shout out instead Luke Edwards Ryan
dude I'm like one of your biggest fans i
watch your videos as soon as you release
them so I thought I'd be an ass kisser
and message you thanks Luke Edwards dude
I am more than happy to be providing
these videos for you ass-kisser it's
okay oh personally Luke Edwards I prefer
if you were an ass licker
lord knows my girlfriend can't do that
to me oh here's me go to the bathroom
too many times fart in the middle of the
night sometimes a fart right after I
wake up right after my crown boys sleep
so she she's on an ass licker but Luke
you could be that guy I get the
impression you would lick my butt
hey Luke mmm
well that's your shadow